[Music]
another week and another Friday I had a
really crazy week this week a lot of
stuff going on basically there was like
a reporter who's found my videos through
its kids and he he wrote an article
about me and he posted it and then they
contacted me again and we're like hey
we're actually gonna print it in the
magazine so I was in the magazine two
days ago thanks to YouTube it's pretty
crazy I will show you here that like a
full page yeah yeah it's pretty cool I
can link the article in the description
if you know Swedish it's in Swedish
yourself it's really crazy because ever
since that article there's been like two
TV networks and other magazines that try
to contact me as well
I don't know like what I did all the
sudden but everyone just wants a piece
of the pie basically literally honestly
I think don't think I'm like the type of
person who I don't I just think there's
probably a lot of other people who would
enjoy this attention a lot more than me
I don't know I'm not the type of person
who wants
being the center of attention but
believe it or not probably no one
believed that like I didn't Sardi's
videos for like being on TV and being in
magazine it I'm not saying I don't like
it but it's a fun thing and to you know
maybe make my parents proud and I think
you bros are proud of me as well so yeah
it's pretty cool I guess I can I can't
complain at least also about the posters
I'm I'm starting to send them out like
hey I'll show you there's me making my
our apartment it's you probably can't
even see it has a [ __ ] ton of boxes and
stuff because that that poster orders
it's like it's so many of them and it's
just taken me forever
I keep getting mails of people like
where's my poster
I'm sorry so it will take a little
longer I'm really working the hardest I
can on it I promise you we'll get your
poster and I will do everything in my
power to make sure you will get it
sooner or later I don't really have that
much to report this week how can I
forget 300,000 subscribers holy shooters
everywhere and that's really insane how
fast we broke the 300,000 thing stuff
thing it's crazy how things I've been
working out lately I just I'm just
really happy just having you bros as an
awesome fanbase I get this it's too much
you bros are just too awesome I just
love everything in this I think I went
from the worst years of my life to the
best years of my life thanks to you bros
and thanks to everything on youtube so
it
I just couldn't be more grateful about
everything so stay awesome bros there's
gonna be like a mutant like a TV or
thing they're gonna come over here on
Monday so I will be it'll be updating
you bros and that as well pretty cool
and fun stuff next week I'll probably
he'll do another challenge [ __ ] that
cinnamon challenge I hope it doesn't get
any more than that I don't like don't
try it kids or adults either I don't
know order dolphins if I have any
dolphins watch dolphins and that's my
dolphin language you know alright so I
think that was pretty much it for this
week's of Friday's with the pit-pat all
I can say is stay awesome bros and i
will be keeping a millions for you
that's pretty much it you ready you're
ready for that
alright in we'll count this down in
Swedish so three draw at bro fish
[Music]
you